et on dirait de danse agitée pour
évoquer cette rencontre emmanuel macron
bangui pierre picard géopolitologue
spécialiste de la chine bonjour merci
d'être avec nous sur arte france
on l'a donc pas mal de points tensions
diplomatiques entre paris et pékin dans
quelle mesure cette visite du chef de la
diplomatie chinoise peut apaiser ces
dissensions toute visite d'un haut
responsable chinois et bienvenue dans le
cadre des relations internationales
notamment que depuis quelques mois on
assiste à une montée en puissance de la
diaspora qui étaient déclenchées par
l'administration américaine à l'égard de
la chine sur tous les plans au niveau
jeu politique au niveau sanitaire et
puis on a vu également des ruptures de
contrat du côté américain par rapport à
des contrats internationaux y compris
sur l'environnement alors cette visite
du premier ministre chinois
elle est important parce que la france
est également une nation importante avec
laquelle la chine a des relations depuis
de nombreuses années mais également un
partenariat stratégique
et comme ça à la fois un partenaire
stratégique de la chine également
historiquement un allié des états unis
est bien la france doit composer entre
les exigences je dirai au fil entre les
américaines et puis j'irai à un climat
que finaux fort ou anti chinois qui
semble régner depuis depuis quelques
mois est globalement depuis la mise en
place du programme amériques à face
est ce qu'il ya un jeu d'équilibriste
finalement pour paris vis-à-vis de la
chine tiraillait vous l'avait dit entre
les états unis et et pékin qui reste un
partenaire commercial important pour
parier oui à la fois juridiques brice et
puis en même temps là la tradition de la
diplomatie française qui essayent où se
veut toujours indépendante et comme en
chine donc multilatérale à savoir une
diplomatique est toujours ouverte
on n'est pas forcé d'être au courant sur
tous les sujets tu étais économique pour
cent ans on négocier et puis
effectivement
signé des partenariats stratégiques en
fait c'est la diplomatie française c'est
tout le contraire de l'isolément
diplomatique
c'est toujours l'ouverture la lucidité
également on n'est pas obligé d'être
d'accord les chinois de pays non plus
mais on est en travail qu ensemble comme
on le fait également sur le plan du
climat
alors cette visite elle est importante
elle vient leur équilibre et un petit
peu les rapports entre eux qui sont
relativement mauvais entre
administrations de truck et la chine
depuis quelques mois
et donc ce sera la france 2
effectivement de de ménager ses amis
américains dont on peut leur faire
plaisir en quelques cents et puis en
même temps de montrer que nous sommes
également à partenaires avec la chine
sur tous les plans
donc pas réel rôle de médiateur c'est ce
que vous essayez de dire vous savez je
pense pas fait la chine
ainsi la chine a besoin de 2,2 de la
france et de bon nombre de pays mais la
chine a une ligne relativement verte et
pacifique
donc comme toute grande nation elle a
bien sûr ses propres intérêts et ses
trois points en jeu de mah la chine
risque d'actes pensons tous la première
puissance mondiale
c'est la raison pour laquelle il ya
cette attaque je dirais américaine
contre la chine a donc bien évidemment
la chine a déjà tout un réseau je dirais
dans le monde de partenariat clinique de
partenariat tj que j'irai de relations
amicales avec de nombreux pays ou tout
simplement de relations diplomatiques
normales et bien évidemment l'apport de
paris en tout cas le partenariat de
paris y compris si nous ne sommes pas
d'accord sur toutes les questions et
totalement important pour la chine qui a
une vision pacifique
dieu a dit que ma 6e et également de
l'économie eux dans le monde à bout de
télécoms sur demande du gouvernement
français va supprimer 3000 antenne
weiwei d'ici 2028 annonceurs qui date
d'hier défiance vis-à-vis de pékin ou
désir d'alignement sur ses voisins
européens
chez chacun peut tirer ses propres
conclusions
moi pour ce qui me concerne je dirais
qu'il s'agit plutôt de faire plaisir à
nos alliés traditionnels américains
je pense qu'elle est les chinois ont dit
plusieurs fois vu qu'ils étaient
partenaires avec d'une endroit sociétés
publiques ou privées occidentales et
qu'ils étaient prêts à accepter tout ça
tout le protocole de contrôle et autres
donc je ne suis pas un expert en
télécommunications et en iran numérique
mais je pense que on est plus prêt à
faire un effort pour faire plaisir je
dirais à la vente et géopolitique que
l'amérique qui se heurte aux vêtements
la chine mais venant d'autres pays
autre point diplomatiques sensibles
hong kong 1 paris a clairement fait
savoir qu'ils ne resteraient pas
inactifs
quelle est sa marge de manoeuvre dans ce
dossier vous savez on dit place il ya
des règles des règles qui sont immuables
à moi que le rock et la guerre ce qui
n'est pas fair tellement l'objectif de
dégradations vis-à-vis de la chine
je vous rappelle quand même que hong
kong comme makau comme d'autres
identités sont historiquement rattachés
à la grande chine
que ce soit la chine impériale que ça
soit une chine plus moderne mais qui
sont les territoires qui nous avons
occupé avec les traités inégaux
à l'époque après la guerre de l'opium et
donc on retrouve le même schéma un peu
je dirais si vous permettez l'expression
un peu néocolonialisme donc vouloir
faire d'autres lois sur le territoire
chinois y compris à hong kong
c'est un petit peu je dirais revoir une
autre époque
surtout quand on connaît très bien comme
comme je le connais et qui effectivement
c'est un lieu effectivement paisible où
l'on peut vivre avec une démocratie
certes non pas direct mais c'est clair
direct
il est ok pour général n'ont pas envie
d'avoir des troubles et des émeutes et
je pense que le prétexte des droits de
l'homme ont condé coûté franchement
rendez-nous allait aller à hong kong et
voyez que mon fils et hong kong et
ouvrait filet hong kong et non seulement
le sens pas malheureux mais ils sont
libres ils ne veulent tout simplement
pas de gaza dernière question
cette visite de wang il intervient huit
mois après le début de la pandémie de
coronavirus c'est que la chine est
pointée du doigt dans sa gestion de la
pandémie notamment par par les états
unis
qu'est ce qui va se dire au cours de
cette rencontre entre emmanuel macron et
son son invité son hôte aujourd'hui à ce
sujet là moi je le rappelle quand même
que nos auditeurs avaient été faits
tateurs à savoir que la chine
contrairement à ce que j'ai entendu il
entendu par don ici ou là inverti lohan
c'est donc l'ensemble des dirigeants de
la planète dès le 7 ou 8 janvier 2020
donc la chine a mis à disposition les
premier séquençage de génomes dont elle
disposait et il n'y a pas de virus
chinois mais il ya un juriste ou contre
comme il n'ya pas de virus américains ou
de virus du vih impliquant efficace donc
pas de racistes anti chinois d'une part
et puis la chine a proposé que depuis
très longtemps une coopération
internationale contre le co lead
elle est aujourd'hui elle développe ses
unités de soins en afrique et donc nous
envoie pays
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut
écouter la demande chinoise qui à mon
avis orale écoute je l'espère de l'union
européenne et des nations européennes à
savoir avoir une lutte commune nos pas
chaque pays replié sur lui-même disait
du coc vide en matière de prévention
mais également pour avoir avec ça
gratuit et pour le plus grand lot merci
pierre picard d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
géopolitologue et spécialiste de la
chine